ungewöhnlich am sonntag die
morgendlichen talkshows ändern ihr
programm präsident trump hat ein
statement angekündigt er bestätigt was
seit dem abend als gerücht die runde
gemacht hatte vergangene nacht haben die
usa den schlimmsten terroristen führer
der welt so bestraft wie er es verdient
al bagdadi ist tot us-spezialkräfte
hatten sich dem versteck albath da dies
im nordwesten syriens genährt in einem
tunnel hätte der sich dann mit einer
sprengstoffweste in die luft gesprengt
die endproben belegten er ist es jobs
selber verfolgte den schlag gegen al
bagdadi im weißen haus am morgen lob für
die operation
al bagdadi war böse und gewalttätig er
starb nun auf gewalttätige weise wie ein
feigling auf der flucht und weinend
dieser überraschungsangriff lief
tadellos al baghdadi zuerst hatte er al
qaida im irak übernommen dann den so
genannten e s begründet eine
schreckensherrschaft über weite teile
iraks und syriens die mit gräueltaten
und blutigen anschlägen die
weltgemeinschaft gegen sich aufbrachte
der schlag in der nacht auch das
endgültige ende des hat eine ideologie
zu zerschlagen
wir müssen also in hab-acht-stellung
bleiben um solche ziele zu zerstören
wenn sie wieder aufkommen trump feiert
sich für diesen schlag betonte
allerdings es bleibt beim abzug der usa
aus syrien
dafür hat er viel kritik einstecken
müssen wir fragen noch mal nach bei m at
wissen in washington der e s verliert
sein führer was bedeutet das jetzt für
diese terror miliz also es ist ohne
zweifel ein ganz wichtiger militärischer
und auch politischer erfolg für die
trump in administration aber abu bakr al
baghdadi hat in den letzten 12 jahren
eigentlich keine entscheidende rolle für
den ie es mehr gespielt der us und seine
ideologie haben sich in dieser zeit
weiter ausgebreitet rund um den erdball
von ländern wie philippinen über
afghanistan bis eben auch nach nord und
ostafrika
und dazu hat beigetragen eine
amerikanische außenpolitik die er auf
rückzug setzt
in den letzten wochen haben wir das ja
gesehen dass durch diesen rückzug
beispielsweise in syrien mehrere hundert
kämpfer und ihre unterstützer entkommen
sind aus den gefängnissen und die lage
in syrien und irak im nachbarstaat hat
sich weiter so die stabilisiert ist das
fruchtbarer boden für diese
islamistische ideologie ist also das
ganze ist ein wichtiger militärischer
erfolg aber den sieg über den as zu
programmieren wie das der us-präsident
getan hat anders als sein eigener
verteidigungsminister das glaube ich ist
eine gefährliche fehleinschätzung